I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Hello, hello. Hi there.
我是詹娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量闺蜜故事，更深入地探秘《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室女郎 6.0。哈喽，哈喽。大家好。
This is a fun episode. It really is. It's a fun episode. I'm excited to do it. It's also a little rainy outside, and we're inside all cozy. I'm just happy to be here. Why don't you tell everybody what we're doing today, Ang? I sure will. Today, it's the superfan basketball episode. We're going to be talking a little bit about some of the new scenes added in. And we have a special guest that's going to join us later. It's Carly Rothenberg, who played Madge from the warehouse. That is right. I mean, Madge is like legend. And Carly, by the way, his... has been acting professionally since 1986. She has a very long-standing career as a guest star actor. I mean, she's been in everything.
这是一集很有趣的节目。真的很有趣。这是一集很有趣的节目。我很兴奋能录制它。外面还在下着小雨，而我们在温暖的室内。我很高兴能来到这里。安吉，你为什么不告诉大家我们今天要做什么呢？我当然会。今天是超级粉丝篮球集。我们要聊聊一些新加入的场景。而且我们稍后还会迎来一位特别嘉宾。她就是饰演仓库里马奇的卡莉·罗滕贝格。没错。我是说，马奇就像是个传奇。顺便说一句，卡莉自……1986年以来就一直在进行专业表演。她作为客串演员有着非常悠久的职业生涯。我是说，她什么都演过。
I can't wait to hear her talk about her time on the office. But first, we're going to kick things off with a chit-chat suggestion. Angela, I am loving these chit-chat suggestions that our office ladies' community have been sending in. They are so fun. And here is a really fun one that mentions the basketball episode from Savannah in Fort Worth. Hi, office ladies. After listening to Second Drink Basketball, I realized it's one of my comfort episodes along with the Dundees,
我等不及要听她讲讲在《办公室》的日子了。但首先，我们要以一个闲聊建议来拉开序幕。安吉，我很喜欢办公室女郎社区发来的这些闲聊建议。它们太有趣了。这里有一个非常有趣的建议，提到了来自沃思堡萨凡纳的篮球那一集。嗨，办公室女郎们。在听了《再来一杯篮球》之后，我意识到这是我的慰藉剧集之一，还有《邓迪奖》、
email surveillance, casino night, and the convention. I was wondering, what are your comfort episodes from your favorite TV shows that y'all like? I love y'all's podcast and the tidbits y'all give. Thanks for letting me ask my question. Oh, Savannah, I just love that you love the tidbits. Okay, so let's answer her question, Jenna's. What are your sort of comfort things to watch? Yeah, I like to watch movies on repeat.
《邮件监视》、《赌场之夜》和《会议》。我想知道，你们最喜欢的电视剧里有哪些是你们喜欢看的慰藉剧集？我超喜欢你们的播客和你们分享的趣闻。谢谢你们让我提问。哦，萨凡纳，我太喜欢你喜欢这些趣闻了。好了，让我们回答她的问题吧，詹娜。你们平时喜欢看什么来慰藉自己？对，我喜欢反复看电影。
So I have a few movies. I think you all know one of my comfort movies is The Edge. Yeah. We broke it down here on Office Ladies. In a two-parter, by the way. Yeah, by the way. I think my three main go-to comfort movies are The Edge, Moonstruck, and Phantom Thread. Do you know Phantom Thread with Daniel Day-Lewis?
所以我有一些电影。我想大家都知道我的一部慰藉电影是《边缘》。对。我们在《办公室女郎》里剖析过它。顺便说一句，分成了上下集。对，顺便说一句。我想我的三部主要常看慰藉电影是《边缘》、《月色撩人》和《霓裳魅影》。你知道由丹尼尔·戴-刘易斯主演的《霓裳魅影》吗？
and he plays the old-timey fashion designer. I watched it three nights ago. What? Yes. I love this movie. We've never discussed it. How am I just learning this now? I love this movie.
他饰演老派的时装设计师。我三天前刚看。什么？对。我超喜欢这部电影。我们从来没讨论过它。我怎么现在才知道这件事？我太喜欢这部电影了。
And so I watched it a long time ago. And then I re-watched it a month ago. And then my son, Jack, was like, I really want to watch that movie. And I said, I'll re-watch it with you again. So I've just watched it twice now in the last five weeks. I love it so much. I love how irritated he gets at the smallest things. I just, when she's like buttering her toast, that's what I could rewatch that scene.
我很久以前看过它。然后一个月前我又重温了一遍。接着我儿子杰克说，我真的很想看那部电影。我说，那我再陪你重温一遍。所以我过去五周里已经看两遍了。我太喜欢它了。我喜欢他在小事上变得那么烦躁。我就是，当她在抹黄油吐司时，我可以反复观看那个场景。
I could live in that scene. It's so delicious. I want to eat the breakfast that he eats in that movie all the time with all the little, like, you know, the butter has its own little dome cover and all the china and all the like accoutrement that comes with his breakfast. Google, one of his breakfast orders, is a rabbit's... Yeah. Oh, crap. What does he call it?
我可以生活在那个场景里。太美妙了。我想一直吃他在那电影里吃的早餐，有所有那些小小的，你知道的，黄油有它自己的小圆顶盖，还有所有的骨瓷餐具，以及伴随他早餐的所有那些用具。谷歌，他的其中一份早餐点单是兔……对。哦，糟了。他叫它什么来着？
I can't remember. Well, it's not actually rabbit. It's just how it's prepared. So we had to Google that. But yeah. Well, Angela, what about you? Do you have a comfort TV show or what? I do.
我记不清了。嗯，其实不是兔子。只是它的制作方式。所以我们不得不去谷歌一下。但是，好吧。那么，安吉，你呢？你有没有什么慰藉电视剧之类的？我有。
I mean, all through the pandemic, we watch the Great British Bake Off. I absolutely love it. I will rewatch an episode of that. If I just need to, like, wind down. It doesn't matter what seasons. I have some favorite seasons. but I will just pop it on. And this goes actually for my whole family, for Josh and the kids.
我是说，整个疫情期间，我们都在看《英国烘焙大赛》。我太喜欢它了。我甚至会重温其中的一集。如果我只是需要，比如说，放松一下。不管哪一季都行。我有一些最喜欢的季节。但我就会随便放着看。实际上这适用于我的全家，乔斯和孩子们。
If we just want something where we don't have time to invest in a whole new episode of something, it's like it's a school night, but we want to watch a little something. We'll watch a Great British Bake Off. I mean, that tracks with Josh as a baker as well. Yeah, yeah. And then, you know, my favorite movie is Pride and Prejudice, and I rewatch it all the time, all the time. I mean, multiple times a year. I'll just put it on and watch it.
如果我们只是想看点什么，而又没有时间投入到一个全新的单集里，比如这是一个上学夜，但我们想稍微看点什么。我们就会看《英国烘焙大赛》。我是说，这很符合乔斯作为一个面包师的身份。对，对。然后，你知道，我最喜欢的电影是《傲慢与偏见》，我一直在重温它，一直在看。我是说，一年好多次。我就会把它放出来看。
Yeah. And I've never seen it. I know. It's just crazy to me. You know, I would say I need you to watch it and us break it down, but I don't think we need to break it down. What I would rather do is have a BFF date and I would make a pot of tea and maybe make some patisserie, maybe like a little like tea party and you and I watch Pride and Prejudice in real life on a couch next to each other. I mean, done. Let's please do this. Okay, great. I'm excited. I'm saying we're looking for a BFF hang. I know. You were looking at like crafting classes. I was looking at like, I wanted to go see the Bisa Butler exhibit, but it closed. And so I think this is our thing. This is going to be our BFF date. Okay.
对。我从来没看过。我知道。这对我来说太疯狂了。你知道，我会说我需要你去看看然后我们一起剖析它，但我觉得我们不需要剖析它。我更想做的是来一次闺蜜约会，我会煮一壶茶，也许做点法式糕点，大概就像一个小茶会，你和我并排坐在沙发上在现实生活中看《傲慢与偏见》。我是说，一言为定。请务必这么做。太好了。我很兴奋。我是说我们在寻找闺蜜聚会。我知道。你当时在看手工艺课。我当时在看，我想去看比萨·巴特勒的展览，但它关门了。所以我想这就是我们的活动。这将是我们的闺蜜约会。好的。
Tea and Pride and Prejudice. Pride and Prejudice. Yay. Oh, Savannah. Thank you so much for sending in your chit-chat suggestion. Everyone, the folder is on OfficeLadies.com. Head over there. Send us your suggestions.
茶和《傲慢与偏见》。《傲慢与偏见》。耶。哦，萨凡纳。非常感谢你发来闲聊建议。大家，文件夹就在 OfficeLadies.com 上。去那里看看吧。把你们的建议发给我们。
But now let's dive into today. Today's episode, we're talking about the superfan episode of basketball, which was written and directed by Greg Daniels. You know, the superfan episode is almost twice as long as the original broadcast version. The broadcast version is 22 minutes and 13 seconds, and the superfan is 39 minutes and 50 seconds. I know. Well, speaking of how much longer this episode is, I reached out to our amazing editor, director of the office, Dave Rogers, And if you guys remember, Dave was on talking about how he put together these superfan episodes, and he made us a list of his top 10 favorites that he's done so far, and basketball made the list.
但现在让我们进入今天的话题。今天的剧集，我们讨论的是篮球超级粉丝版，由格雷格·丹尼尔斯编剧并执导。你知道，超级粉丝版的长度几乎是原本播出版的两倍。播出版是22分13秒，而超级粉丝版是39分50秒。我知道。说到这集有多长，我联系了我们优秀的剪辑师、《办公室》的导演戴夫·罗杰斯，如果大家还记得的话，戴夫曾上过节目讲述他是如何将这些超级粉丝版剪辑到一起的，他给我们列出了他迄今为止最喜欢的10个榜单，而《篮球》就上了榜。
So I asked him to share about it, and here's what he had to say about the additional footage. And I quote, there are 13 minutes of deleted scenes restored. These are scenes that were either on the DVDs or the NBC website, and then there's about six minutes of new material added that no one's. ever seen. Okay. Okay. This episode is a great example of what the superfan episodes are all about.
所以我请他分享一下相关情况，以下是他对新增素材的看法。我引用他的话：“有13分钟被删减的镜头被恢复了。这些镜头要么在DVD上，要么在NBC网站上，然后大约有6分钟是从未有人见过的新素材。”好吧。好吧。这一集是超级粉丝版意义的一个极好例证。
To have these great deleted scenes and new material restored within the context of the show as opposed to just seeing them loose are tied together with other deleted scenes. And then he sent me his itemized list of each scene he added back in. It's just so impressive the amount of work him and his team are doing. It was like two pages of a list. And it tells you if it's a deleted. scene are new material, newfound stuff, right? Wow. Well, I thoroughly enjoyed this superfan episode. Me too. The basketball superfan episode kicks off the same way that the broadcast
将这些精彩的删除镜头和新素材在剧集背景下恢复，而不是仅仅把它们零散地看，或者与其他删除镜头绑在一起。然后他发给我一份他加回的每个场景的逐项清单。他和他的团队所做的工作量真是太让人印象深刻了。列了大概有两页纸的清单。上面会告诉你它是删除镜头还是新素材、新发现的东西，对吧？哇。好吧，我非常享受这个超级粉丝版。我也是。篮球超级粉丝版的开场方式和广播
version does with Michael entering and asking Jim if he's ready. And then they show one another their gym bags. And then Michael points to Ryan and Ryan holds up his bag. Well, we got a question from Kelly C. in Pittsburgh, who said this. My question is from the basketball episode. When Michael is going around the bullpen asking if everyone brought their clothes, Ryan holds up a plastic bag that seems sealed up like it was an online clothing order. It made me think that Ryan had to order something to wear to play basketball in the office that day. Because otherwise, it might have been a duffel or a bag from home. I notice that every time I see that episode and imagine that Ryan had to place an Amazon order for athletic wear because Michael wanted him to play.
版本一样，迈克尔走进来问吉姆准备好了没有。然后他们向对方展示各自的健身包。接着迈克尔指向瑞安，瑞安举起了他的包。嗯，我们收到了来自匹兹堡的凯莉·C. 的一个问题，她是这么说的：我的问题来自篮球那一集。当迈克尔在办公室里四处询问大家是否带了衣服时，瑞安举起了一个看起来像网购衣服那样密封着的塑料袋。这让我觉得瑞安那天不得不为了在办公室打篮球而网购了一些东西。因为否则的话，那应该是一个行李袋或家里带来的包。每次看到那一集我都会注意到这一点，并想象瑞安因为迈克尔想让他打球而不得不去亚马逊下单购买运动服。
Well, Kelly, I think you're on to something. I went to the shooting draft of basketball, and in the script, the writers wrote in very specific descriptions of everyone's bag. What did it say? It says, quote, Jim holds up an athletic bag. Michael holds up a Nike bag. Dwight holds up an Adidas bag. And Ryan holds up a shirt.
嗯，凯莉，我觉得你猜到点子上了。我看了《篮球》的拍摄初稿，在剧本里，编剧对每个人的包写了非常具体的描述。上面是怎么写的？上面写着，引述：“吉姆举起一个运动包。迈克尔举起一个耐克包。德怀特举起一个阿迪达斯包。而瑞安举起一个购物袋。”
shopping bag. See, it was completely intentional. Yes, Kelly, I think Ryan had to quickly buy clothes to play basketball in. I always noticed that bag, too, by the way, so I love that question. Sidebar. Yeah. Growing up, my friends called Adidas, because they were from Australia. Oh, that's how they talk about it on that British show, Glow Up. Do you know Glow Up? I don't. Okay, it's great British baking show except makeup. Oh. So it's a bunch of makeup artists. and they're vying to be the winner of doing makeup. And they had a campaign one season for Adidas. Yeah.
看，这完全是故意的。是的，凯莉，我觉得瑞安不得不赶紧买衣服来打篮球。顺便说一句，我也一直注意到那个包，所以我很喜欢这个问题。顺便说一下。对。在我成长过程中，我的朋友们把阿迪达斯（Adidas）叫作Adidas，因为他们来自澳大利亚。哦，他们在那个英国节目《Glow Up》里就是这么说的。你知道《Glow Up》吗？我不知道。好吧，它就像是《英国烘焙大赛》，只不过主角是化妆。哦。所以是一群化妆师。他们在争夺化妆比赛的冠军。有一季他们为阿迪达斯做过一个活动。对。
I know. And so now my daughter and I call it Adidas. Yeah. I always almost call it Adidas because that's what I heard growing up. Anyway, sorry. Okay. I want to bring up this. There's a new bit that's added to the superfan episode.
我知道。所以现在我和我女儿叫它Adidas。对。我几乎总是叫它Adidas，因为我从小就是这么听来的。不管怎样，抱歉。好的。我想提一下这个。超级粉丝版里增加了一个新桥段。
When Michael goes to get his messages from Pam at front reception, we learn we're Michael shops for his pants, y'all, and I thought you had to hear it. Pam, Pam, thank you, ma'am. Messages, please. Thank you all. New pants? Yes. Thank you for noticing.
当迈克尔去前台找帕姆拿留言时，我们知道了迈克尔在哪买裤子，各位，我觉得你们一定要听听。帕姆，帕姆，谢谢你，女士。留言，请。谢谢大家。新裤子？是的。谢谢你注意到。
I really like those pleats, Michael. Oh, they're, you know. Abercrombie and Fitch? They look that good. Wow. Oh, Pam. Please behave. Mike Myers, genius.
我真的很喜欢那些褶皱，迈克尔。哦，它们是，你知道的。Abercrombie & Fitch？看起来那么好。哇。哦，帕姆。请放尊重点。麦克·迈尔斯，天才。
No, actually, I got them at a fancier place. Targe. Oh, I'm sorry. Targey. Michael shops for pants at Target, everybody. I know. I love that, but I also love the Targeet because, you know, that's what the ladies in my family say. Targeet or Jacques Pinet.
不，其实我是从一个更高级的地方买的。Targe。哦，抱歉。Targey。各位，迈克尔去塔吉特买裤子。我知道。我喜欢那个，但我也喜欢“Targeet”，因为，你知道，我家里的小姐们就是这么说的。Targeet 或者雅各·帕内。
What's Jacques Panet? J.C. Pennies. I don't know that one. I love that. Well, another fun thing about the Superfan episode is that we are going to finally find out exactly what went wrong at this pickup basketball game with Todd Packer. Oh, that was one of my favorite scenes in the original broadcast. Todd Packer? Like, Michael is so embarrassed. I want to know why. Yes, in the broadcast version, there's this scene
什么是雅各·帕内？J.C. 彭尼。我不知道那个。我喜欢。好吧，关于超级粉丝版的另一个有趣之处在于，我们终于要弄清楚这场和托德·帕克的接头篮球赛到底出了什么问题。哦，那是原版播映中最喜欢的场景之一。托德·帕克？就像，迈克尔太尴尬了。我想知道为什么。是的，在播出版里，有这样一个场景
in Michael's office, and Dwight is begging to be in the basketball game in the warehouse, and Michael is saying no, not after what happened at that game, that pickup game I invited you to. You know, he's like, I vouched for you in front of Todd Packer. Todd Packer! Yes. Well, in the superfan version, we cut away to a Dwight talking head, and here's what happened. Oh. The pickup game incident.
在迈克尔的办公室里，德怀特恳求去仓库参加篮球赛，而迈克尔说不行，在发生那场比赛、我邀请你去的那场接头篮球赛之后绝对不行。你知道，他就好像，我在托德·帕克面前为你作保。托德·帕克！是的。好吧，在超级粉丝版里，画面切到了德怀特的一个访谈镜头，事情是这样的。哦。接头篮球赛事件。
Well, what happened is I missed a couple passes that Michael threw me. I should have dove for them. I think about it all the time. Why didn't I die for them? That's it. That's it? That's it. He should have dove for a couple of passes.
嗯，发生的事情是我漏掉了几个迈克尔传给我的球。我本该扑过去接住它们的。我无时无刻不在想这件事。我当时为什么不扑过去呢？就是这样。就这样？就这样。他本应该扑过去接几个传球的。
I mean, he's, Michael has been holding this grudge. It just sounds like Dwight didn't even really do anything that bad. He didn't. Also, I'm willing to bet those passes were just wild and crazy and out of his reach. I mean, in the basketball game, we see Michael trying to throw a pass and it goes like into the warehouse truck. Like, yes. Yeah. Yes.
我是说，他，迈克尔一直记恨到现在。听起来德怀特根本没做什么太坏的事。他确实没做。另外，我敢打赌那些传球本来就又野又疯狂，根本够不着。我是说，在篮球比赛中，我们看到迈克尔试图传球，结果传到了仓库卡车里。就像，对。是的。对。
Mm-hmm. Oh, Dwight. I know. All right. the next new scene we want to talk about is back at front reception. I love this moment. I'm going to describe it for you guys. Pam has taken it on herself to glue a piece of the desk panel that wraps around the front reception desk, right? It's just like that laminate peeling, you know, on a desk, and it's cheapy, and it's just popping off. So she's got a little bit of glue,
嗯哼。哦，德怀特。我知道。好啦。我们要聊的下一个新场景是在前台接待处。我喜欢这个时刻。我来为你们描述一下。帕姆自作主张地用胶水粘合环绕前台接待桌的一块桌板，对吧？就像那种桌子上剥落的层压板，你知道的，很廉价，然后正翘起来。所以她拿了一点胶水，
like Elmer's glue, and she's trying to stick it back together. I just love this little moment because how many times have you, like, worked somewhere, and this desk has, like, got a flap hanging off of it or something? Yes. It's happened to me. Me too. Anyway, Jim walks up, and they start to be kind of flirty flirt. He grabs the glue and starts to glue all his hand.
就像埃尔默胶水，她正试图把它粘回去。我太喜欢这个小插曲了，因为你曾几何时在某处工作过，而这张桌子上面挂着一块翻起来的皮或者别的什么，这种情况发生过多少次？是的。我遇到过。我也是。不管怎样，吉姆走了过来，他们开始眉来眼去。他抓起胶水，开始把胶水弄满整只手。
You know, he lays his palm out and does glue all over the palm of his hands. And he's like, did you do this growing up? You know, how you'd put glue on your hand, then you'd let it dry, and then you'd peel it off, like you had a little second piece of skin. and they giggle, and he does this. And then, so he's got two hands full of glue, and then they both are blowing on his hands. It's very flirty.
你知道，他摊开手掌，把胶水弄满了整个手掌。然后他说，你小时候做过这个吗？你知道，你是怎么把胶水弄在手上，然后让它变干，接着把它撕下来，就像你有一小层第二层皮肤一样。然后他们咯咯笑，他就是这么做的。然后呢，他的两只手上都沾满了胶水，接着他们两个都在对着他的手吹气。非常调情。
Pam is gently blowing on his hand. Let me just say, mm-hmm, mm-hmm. Then the phone rings at front reception, and she's got to answer it, and it's Roy's mom, Vicky. And she ends up being on the phone with Vicki for a while, and it just gets awkward. And Jim is now just standing there with glue on his hands.
帕姆温柔地对着他的手吹气。我只想说，嗯哼，嗯哼。然后前台的电话响了，她得接电话，打来的是罗伊的妈妈维基。最后她和维基通了好一会儿电话，气氛变得有点尴尬。而吉姆现在就站在那里，手上都是胶水。
He eventually just walks away, and goes into the kitchen and washes the glue off his hands. It's a real womp, womp. So this is one of those scenes when I saw it in the Superfan episode. I had forgotten that we did this and all these memories came pouring back. So the first thing that I remember is talking with Greg Daniels about glue, about doing silly things with glue and with John. And we talked about how did you do that thing with glue where I would glue like in the shape of a fingernail and let it dry and then I would peel the glue off and I would put it on my fingernail once it had hardened and then I would color it with marker.
他最后只好走开，走进厨房把手上的胶水洗掉。这真让人大失所望。所以这是我在超级粉丝版中看到时觉得属于那种的场景之一。我已经忘了我们拍过这个，然后所有的回忆如潮水般涌来。所以我的第一段记忆是和格雷格·丹尼尔斯谈论胶水，谈论和约翰一起用胶水做一些愚蠢的事情。我们谈到你是怎么用胶水的，比如我会把胶水挤成指甲的形状让它变干，然后把干了的胶水撕下来，等它变硬后贴在我的指甲上，接着用马克笔给它上色。
I never did that. And I told them this story. And John was like, oh, I used to put it on my hands and you rub your hands together until it gets sticky. and then it becomes sort of like a putty, and you can play with it after you peel it off your hands. Well, I did the exact thing that he's doing, which is I glued my whole hand and I let it dry.
我从来没那样做过。我把这个故事讲给他们听。约翰就说，哦，我以前把它抹在手上，然后双手互相揉搓直到它变黏。然后它有点像油漆灰泥，从手上撕下来后你还可以玩它。好吧，我做了和他完全一样的事，那就是我在整只手上抹了胶水，然后等它变干。
You have to wait a while. And then I slowly peeled it off. And then it was like you were seeing my hand, but a thin glue version of my hand. Yes. Why we got into this conversation, I don't know. But then Greg made it a scene. He turned it into this romantic, intimate, blowing on his hands sort of scene.
你得等上一会儿。然后我慢慢把它撕下来。接着就像是你看到我的手，但那是一个薄薄的胶水版的手。我们为什么会聊到这个，我不知道。但后来格雷格把它拍成了一个场景。他把它变成了一种浪漫、亲密、对着他的手吹气的场景。
It was incredible. And then I remember when it was time for the phone call, I only had one scripted line. I was just supposed to be like, oh, hey, Vicky, yeah, I think I can run by and grab that. And then Greg just kept the camera rolling, and I just was improvving this conversation with Vicky. And then John is standing there as Jim with his hands covered in glue. It was so wonderful. But it took a lot of time, you know, and that's the sort of stuff we didn't have time for in the broadcast versions. But I loved it.
这太不可思议了。然后我记得到了该打那个电话的时候，我只有一句台词是写进剧本里的。我本该表现得像，哦，嘿，维基，是的，我想我可以跑过去拿那个。然后格雷格就让摄像机一直转着，我一直在即兴发挥和维基的这段对话。接着吉姆就站在那里，手上沾满胶水。这太棒了。但这花了很多时间，你知道，这就是我们在播出版中没有时间去做的那些内容。但我很喜欢它。
I loved the scene was back in. It was romantic and then cringy all at the same time. It also made me nostalgic of a childhood without devices because I think what you did was you put glue on your hands. Yes. Right? You didn't have an iPad to keep you company. So I love you. it. So there's a few other storylines that were beefed up for the superfan version. And one was about
我很喜欢这个场景被加了回来。它既浪漫又让人尴尬。这也让我怀念起那个没有电子设备的童年，因为我觉得你做的事就是把胶水弄到手上。是的。对吧？你可没有iPad来陪伴你。所以我很喜欢它。所以还有其他一些为超级粉丝版加强的故事线。其中一个是关于
Dwight doing the schedule, right, if he would have to work on Saturdays. So there's more of that. Like, people are going to him and presenting their cases of, like, why they shouldn't have to work. There's also, like, a full 30 seconds of him trying to put his giant dry erase board under his desk. Yeah. And it's just, it's straight up wrestling. Yeah. With this giant whiteboard, it was hilarious. I know. Rain is so good. at that kind of physical humor. And then the other thing that's been beefed up is everything down in the warehouse.
德怀特做排班表，对吧，如果他周六得上班的话。所以这方面的内容更多了。比如，大家去找他并陈述他们为什么不应该上班的理由。还有，比如足足有30秒钟他试图把巨大的白板塞到他的办公桌底下。是的。而且，这简直就是肉搏战。是的，跟这个巨大的白板，太搞笑了。我知道。雷恩真的太擅长
There's just so much more trash talk. But one of my favorite things that made its way into this extended version was a Pam talking head. So it would have come right after we learned that she's been engaged for three years, has no wedding date set, right? Yep.
那种身体喜剧了。然后另一件被加强的事情就是仓库里的所有内容。
And lady, it's the thing you pitch to Greg about Roy and the Wave Runners. This is like this extended moment. We have to hear it. Well, I thought we were saving money for the wedding, but apparently Roy thought it was more important to buy two wave runners. I don't really ever even get to use the other wave runner that's supposed to be mine because his brother uses it and they race. I'm not going to lie. I actually laughed out loud at myself when I watched this talking at it. It took me by surprise. And it's very funny to me. And they race is the line that got me.
垃圾话实在是太多了。但进入这个加长版的最让我喜欢的片段之一，是一个帕姆的访谈镜头。它会紧接着我们得知她已经订婚三年却没有定下婚礼日期的时候出现，对吧？没错。
Yeah. But this is this. This is the thing. You pitched to Greg that he, he, like, wasted, like, the money to plan the wedding to buy these stupid wave runners. Yeah, Greg asked me one day, why do you think Pam and Roy aren't married yet? And I said, oh, I have a whole story for that. And then he put it in. It's so great.
而且，女士，这就是你向格雷格推销的关于罗伊和水上摩托艇的事。这就像是一个加长的时刻。我们得听听。嗯，我以为我们是在为婚礼攒钱，但显然罗伊觉得买两台水上摩托艇更重要。我其实从来都没用过那台本该属于我的水上摩托艇，因为他弟弟在用，而且他们赛车。说实话，当我看这个访谈时，我真的对自己笑出了声。这让我很意外。而且我觉得这非常搞笑。“而且他们赛车”这句台词戳中了我。
It's so perfect, too. Okay, so the Superfan episode also includes a big plot twist that is not in the broadcast version. So Michael is in the bullpen, and he's trying to pick his team. He says it's going to be him, Ryan, Stanley, Jim, and wait for it, Todd Packer. Todd Packer was going to play in the basketball game. We find out this, I couldn't believe. Guess what his position is?
对。但这就是这个。这就是那回事。你向格雷格推销说他，他把筹备婚礼的钱都给浪费了，去买这些蠢水上摩托艇。对，格雷格有一天问我，你觉得为什么帕姆和罗伊还没结婚？我说，哦，我为此准备了整整一个故事。然后他就把它放进去了。这太棒了。
Point guard. Yes, Phyllis, who wants to play in the game and is denied, is like, Todd Packer doesn't even really work here. And Jim is like, I thought this game was just for fun, like sort of being like, why can't Phyllis play? And Michael's like, yeah, yeah, yeah, but Packer's really good. And I just have to call him. I have to confirm he's in.
这也太完美了。好吧，超级粉丝版还包含了一个在播出版中没有的巨大剧情反转。所以迈克尔在办公区里，他正试图挑选他的队伍。他说将由他、瑞安、斯坦利、吉姆，还有，等等，托德·帕克组成。托德·帕克要来参加篮球赛。我们发现了这一点，我简直不敢相信。你猜他的位置是什么？
So Michael goes into his office, he puts him on speakerphone. And Packer is completely Packer, totally inappropriate. And then he just bales on the game. But what's crazy is that it's not Dave Kekner on the phone because Dave Kekner had not been cast yet. Yep. I'm assuming that it was Toby Huss who originated the voice of Todd Packer before Dave was cast. You reached out to Dave Raj.
控球后卫。是的，菲利斯想参加比赛却被拒绝了，她说：“托德·帕克甚至都不怎么在这里上班。”而吉姆则说：“我以为这场比赛只是为了好玩，就像是……为什么菲利斯不能上场？”然后迈克尔说：“对，对，对，但帕克真的很厉害。我必须给他打个电话。我得确认他加入。”
right, Anj? I did. I asked him about it, and I said, was that Toby? And also, did it bump you to add this back in because ultimately the role became Dave Kekner's role, right? And here's what Dave said. He said, you ladies are correct. That is not Dave Kekner. But I had no issue adding back this beat because Packer is played by the only other person who had ever played him on the show, and that is Toby Huss. Toby originally voiced Todd Packer in the pilot episode when Michael is sitting with Pam and Jan in his office and he takes a call from Packer on speakerphone. And if you remember, he's almost immediately inappropriate and saying things about Jan. Well, that was Toby Huss. And then Dave went on to say, and for the scene in
所以迈克尔走进他的办公室，把他设成了免提。帕克完全就是个帕克，极其不得体。然后他直接放鸽子不来比赛了。但疯狂的是，接电话的人不是戴夫·凯克纳，因为当时戴夫·凯克纳还没被选上。没错。我猜是托比·胡斯，在戴夫被选上之前，他是托德·帕克声音的最初扮演者。你联系了戴夫·罗杰斯，
basketball, I not only love Packers and appropriateness, but it also illuminates the stress Michael has put on himself with this game when you get to see moments like this because his star player has just bailed on him. Yeah, I thought this was actually pretty cool. You know, a lot of the extra footage in the basketball super fan happens before the basketball game. I noticed there's a little bit added to the actual game, but most of it is this tension. You get more of the romantic tension between Jim and Pam, and then you get this tension of what is the team going to be. So I liked it too, and I like because it's all adding to the stakes. It's all adding to Michael's stress. One of the other things that's added back in that I loved are so many non-speaking moments. Like you said, up in the
对吧，安吉？是的。我问了他这件事，我说，那是托比吗？而且，把这个加回来有没有让你觉得膈应，因为这个角色最终成了戴夫·凯克纳的角色，对吧？戴夫是这样说的。他说：“女士们，你们说得对。那不是戴夫·凯克纳。但我加回这段情节没有任何问题，因为帕克是由剧里唯一一个曾经扮演过他的人饰演的，那就是托比·胡斯。在试播集中，迈克尔和帕姆还有简坐在他的办公室里，他接听了帕克打来的免提电话，托比最初就是为托德·帕克配音的。如果你还记得的话，他几乎立刻就表现得很不得体，还说了一些关于简的话。好吧，那确实是托比·胡斯。”然后戴夫接着说：“至于篮球的那场戏，我不仅喜欢帕克的不得体，当看到这样的时刻时，它还突显了迈克尔在这场比赛中给自己施加的压力，因为他的明星球员刚刚放了他鸽子。”
bullpen, all these people are shooting like baskets of like trash into their trash bins. And they're all really good at making the shot. The only person that misses is Stanley. And Dwight. And Dwight. Right. But you just get to see the full bullpen do it. And then the other thing I loved was all the stretching. Michael does so much stretching. Yes. So much stretching. And the camera angles. Oh, my God. It's a real low angle. He does this one stretch. He's on the ground.
是的，我觉得这其实挺酷的。你知道，《篮球》超级粉丝版中很多额外的镜头都发生在篮球比赛之前。我注意到实际比赛中加了一点点，但大部分都是这种紧张感。你得到了吉姆和帕姆之间更多的浪漫紧张感，然后你得到了这支队伍究竟会是怎样的紧张感。所以我也很喜欢它，我喜欢它是因为这都在增加赌注。这都在增加迈克尔的压力。加回来的我喜爱的另一件事就是有那么多的非对白时刻。就像你说的，在办公区楼上，所有人都在把一团团垃圾投进垃圾桶里。而且他们投球都超级准。唯一投不进的人是斯坦利。还有德怀特。还有德怀特。对。但你就能看到整个办公区的人都在这么做。然后我喜欢的另一件事就是所有的拉伸动作。迈克尔做了大量的拉伸。是的。大量的拉伸。还有摄像机的角度。天哪。这是一个非常低的俯拍角度。他做了这样一个拉伸。他在地上，
I don't know what kind of stretch it is, but the camera is just crotch up. It's ridiculous. So I know I said that a lot of the extra material comes before the basketball game, but there are a lot of extra shots in the basketball game. And in particular, there are a lot of shots of Michael throwing the ball out of the warehouse doors as he's trying to shoot a basket. Like, there's so many more of those. I was going to count how many, but after I got to eight, I stopped counting. He also calls like a million fouls on nothing.
我不知道那是什么拉伸，但摄像机简直是从胯部往上拍。这太荒谬了。所以我知道我之前说过很多额外的素材都发生在篮球比赛之前，但在篮球比赛中其实也有很多额外的镜头。特别是，有很多迈克尔试图投篮时把球扔出仓库大门的镜头。就像，有太多这样的镜头了。我本打算数数有多少个，但数到八个之后我就不数了。他还为一些根本不算犯规的情况吹了好几百万次犯规。
So many. So that's some of the humor that's added back to the basketball game. Okay, well, speaking of Michael and his antics on the court, I wanted to share this. So before I even watched the superfan episode, I was reading Dave Rogers' list of added basketball moments. they're almost all about Michael. And Jenna, just reading Dave's list, just reading it, made me laugh out loud. This is just part of it. Listen to how hilarious these are.
太多了。所以这就是加回到篮球比赛中的一些幽默。好的，说到迈克尔和他在球场上的滑稽举动，我想分享这个。所以在观看超级粉丝版之前，我正在读戴夫·罗杰斯列出的新增篮球时刻清单。它们几乎全都是关于迈克尔的。而且詹娜，光是读着戴夫的清单，光是读着它，就让我大声笑了出来。这只是其中一部分。听听这些有多搞笑。
Ready? Mm-hmm. Michael throws basketball over the backboard. I told you. Mm-hmm. About four feet away, Michael yells three shoots and hits the front of the rim. That one is hilarious. Mm-hmm.
准备好了吗？嗯哼。迈克尔把篮球扔过了篮板。我告诉过你的。嗯哼。大约四英尺远，迈克尔大喊“三次投篮”然后砸中了篮筐前沿。那个太搞笑了。嗯哼。
Michael throws basketball into rafters and complains his ACL is bothering him. Michael calls foul on Daryl for double dribble. Michael calls foul because someone got his hand. Michael calls foul on Roy, illegal use of hands and arms. Michael calls foul on Lonnie, who doesn't touch him. Michael is exhausted and subs out and Phyllis goes in. Michael sits on the bench next to Angela and Pam about to throw up and Phyllis scores. That throw-up scene is so great.
迈克尔把篮球扔进屋顶横梁，并抱怨他的前十字韧带在作痛。迈克尔吹罚达里尔两次运球犯规。迈克尔因为有人碰到他的手而吹犯规。迈克尔吹罗伊犯规，非法使用手和手臂。迈克尔吹洛尼犯规，而洛尼根本没碰他。迈克尔累坏了被换下场，菲利斯上场。迈克尔坐在安吉拉和帕姆旁边板凳上快要吐了，而菲利斯进球了。那个呕吐的场景太棒了。
He sits next to us and just proceeds to gag. It was so hard not to laugh. I think the basketball episode is a really good example of its very, very documentary style because there are so many little bitty moments that we did not have time for in the original version. I totally see why Dave loves this super fan version so much. Yeah. Well, I have one last thing I want to share. It's a background catch by Angela Kay in Los Angeles.
他坐在我们旁边，接着就开始作呕。太难忍住不笑了。我觉得《篮球》这一集是一个非常好的例子，它极具纪录片风格，因为里面有太多原版中我们没有时间展现的小小高光时刻。我完全明白为什么戴夫这么喜欢这个超级粉丝版了。是的。好吧，我还有最后一件事想分享。这是洛杉矶的安吉拉·K捕捉到的一个背景细节。
Okay. What does she have to say? If you go to 27 minutes and 21 seconds, you will see Oscar doing something in the background of the basketball game. Do you remember what he was doing? Yeah, he was like doing work. No. Is that what you mean? No.
好的。她有什么要说的吗？如果你看到27分21秒，你会看到奥斯卡在篮球比赛的背景中做着某件事。你还记得他在做什么吗？对，他在干活。不对。你是那个意思吗？不对。
What's he doing? He's reading the paper. The newspaper. Oscar is reading the local newspaper. And I thought. You're doing a paper tie-in. I was like, what foreshadowing? Like, Oscar is reading the local Scranton newspaper.
他在干嘛？他在看报纸。报纸。奥斯卡在看当地报纸。我当时想。你这是在做纸质联动。我当时想，这是什么伏笔？就像，奥斯卡在看斯克兰顿当地的报纸。
That's pretty perfect. I mean, right? He does love a local paper, I guess. I don't know. It got me tickled, so I just thought I'd bring it up. Well, listen, this feels like a good time to take a break. And when we come back, we will have Carly Rothenberg in studio with us. But since you mentioned it, Angela, this also seems like a good time to remind people that starting in the new year, we are going to be breaking down every episode of the paper.
这太完美了。我是说，对吧？我猜他确实很喜欢本地报纸。不知道。这让我觉得很好笑，所以我才想提出来。好吧，听着，现在感觉是个休息的好时机。当我们回来时，卡莉·罗滕贝格将和我们一起在录音室里。但既然你提到了，安吉拉，这也似乎是个好时机提醒大家，从新的一年开始，我们将剖析《纸业公司》的每一集。
because it's now showing on NBC on Monday nights at 830. So watch it. Head over to OfficeLadies.com. Send us your questions and join us in the new year for those breakdowns. And you know we're going to do it right because we still chat with everybody who's working on the paper. So we're going to get all the inside scoop for you. I mean, we already have emails out to Kelly Cantley, Ken Quappas, Dave Rogers, Michael Komen, Greg Daniels, Chelsea Fry. We're already chatting with people.
因为它现在每周一晚8点半在NBC播出。所以去看吧。前往 OfficeLadies.com。给我们发问题，并在新年加入我们一起来剖析这些剧集。你知道我们会做好的，因为我们仍然会和所有参与《纸业公司》工作的人聊天。所以我们会为你获取所有的内部独家消息。我是说，我们已经给凯利·坎特利、肯·夸帕斯、戴夫·罗杰斯、迈克尔·科门、格雷格·丹尼尔斯、切尔西·弗莱发了邮件。我们已经在和大家聊天了。
That's right, guys. But that's for the new year. After the break, is our interview with Carly Rothenberg, aka Madge from the Warehouse. Make your home smell as good as it looks with Pura 4, the smart fragrance diffuser that lets you control your scent from anywhere. Choose from hundreds of premium fragrances, schedule your favorites, and set the perfect mood for every moment. And right now, get yours free when you subscribe to two cents for 12 months. Don't wait, this limited time offer won't last. Try it risk-free for 30 days now at pura.com.
没错，伙计们。但这那是为了新的一年。休息过后，是我们对卡莉·罗滕贝格的采访，也就是仓库里的马奇。让你的家闻起来和看起来一样棒，使用 Pura 4，这款智能香氛扩散器让你可以随时随地控制你的气味。从数百种优质香水选择中挑选，安排你最喜欢的，并为每个时刻设置完美的氛围。现在，当你订阅两种香味 12 个月时，即可免费获得你的扩散器。不要等待，这个限时优惠不会持续太久。现在就在 pura.com 上进行 30 天无风险试用。
Hello. Hello. Carly, how are you? It's so nice to have you in the studio with us. Thank you for having. Welcome to all this, ladies. It's very exciting to be here. Hello.
你好。你好。卡莉，你好吗？很高兴你能来到我们的录音室。谢谢你们邀请我。欢迎来到办公室女郎。很高兴来到这里。你好。
You brought stuff. I did. I mean, you brought us roses. You brought us jingle jangle. Jingle jingle. The best holiday snack ever for anyone that has a but you also have a folder. What is this? I dug through. I actually started by looking for my original basketball script. Oh, wow. Which I know everybody autographed. Oh, yeah. Yeah. And it is
你带了东西。我带了。我是说，你给我们带了玫瑰。你给我们带了零食拼盘。零食拼盘。对于任何一个有……但你也有一个文件夹。这是什么？我翻找了一下。我其实一开始是去找我原本的篮球剧本。哦，哇。我知道每个人都在上面签了名。哦，是的。是的，它
somewhere in my file cabinet encased in something sealed because, and I couldn't find it. But I did find my original audition. Oh, oh, Carly, that's so good. And your visitors pass. And my visitors pass for my audition for the, for match, which I didn't audition for match. I auditioned with Jerry's lines. They used to do that, though.
在我的文件柜里的某个地方，被封存在某个密封的东西里，因为，而我找不到它。但我确实找到了我最初的试镜。哦，哦，卡莉，太棒了。还有你的访客通行证。还有我为马奇试镜的访客通行证，我其实不是为马奇试镜的。我是用杰瑞的台词试镜的。不过他们以前经常那样做。
They would have just one scene that everybody read and then like Jerry, warehouse worker. Right. And then they would kind of get to know you or your personality, and they'd be like, I have an idea. So I wonder if that's what happened with Match. Well, I think what happened was they were auditioning me for Madge, the warehouse gal, but they didn't have any lines for me. Yeah, not yet. Because she didn't have any lines.
他们会准备一段每个人都要读的场景，然后像杰瑞，仓库工人。对。然后他们就会稍微了解你或者你的个性，然后他们会说，我有个主意。所以我纳闷马奇是不是也是这么回事。嗯，我觉得发生的情况是他们当时在为仓库女孩马奇对我进行试镜，但他们没有给我任何台词。对，还没有。因为她没有任何台词。
So they had me read Jerry's part, and it was on October 11, 2004. Wow. At 10.20 in the morning to see Allison Jones at Cincinnati. at Gower Studios, and I was reading the role of Jerry, and I auditioned with Marla, not with Allison. I remember Marla put me on camera. Okay. I remember Marla? Well, Marla interviewed me after that, and she says, do you play basketball? And I said, sort of, I'm a nanny to a little boy, and at the time I was taking care of a little boy whose name is Joshua. He's the best human being ever. And I think at the time he was like six or seven, we played horse in his front yard.
所以他们让我读杰瑞的部分，那是2004年10月11日。哇。早上10点20分在高尔工作室见艾莉森·琼斯，我读的是杰瑞的角色，我是和玛拉一起试镜的，而不是和艾莉森。我记得玛拉把我拍进了镜头。好的。我记得玛拉？嗯，玛拉在那之后采访了我，她说，你会打篮球吗？我说，算是吧，我是一个小男孩的保姆，当时我照顾的一个小男孩名叫约书亚。他是世界上最好的人。我想他当时大概六七岁，我们在他前院玩马术投篮游戏。
Like every day after school, he would like, come on, we got to play horse. So you were shooting hoops? That was the extent of it. And I was terrible at it. I was absolutely terrible at it. But my dad and my brother had taught me how to play basketball when I was a kid. But all I ever did was play horse. And I think my dad, at the most, would pick me up and help me shoot the basket. I was horrible at basketball. I couldn't dribble. So what did you say to Marla when she asked you? I said I can play horse.
就像每天放学后，他都会说，来吧，我们得玩投篮游戏。所以你在投篮？那就是全部了。而且我打得一塌糊涂。我绝对打得一塌糊涂。但我爸爸和我哥哥在我小时候教过我怎么打篮球。但我做过的全部事情就是玩投篮游戏。我想我爸最多也就是把我抱起来帮我把球投进篮筐。我篮球打得太烂了。我不会运球。所以你对玛拉怎么说的？我说我会玩投篮游戏。
I have a little boy that I take care of that I play horse with. But that's about the extent of my basketball experience. And she goes, okay, okay, great. I am shocked learning this information because we just rewatched the basketball episode. And I think you play very well. I would never know. You said you don't dribble? I'm like, I have no memory of you being a bad dribble.
我照顾的小男孩会和我一起玩投篮游戏。但这差不多就是我篮球经验的全部了。她说，好的，好的，太棒了。听到这个消息我太震惊了，因为我们刚刚重温了篮球那一集。我觉得你打得很好。我绝对看不出来。你说你不会运球？我想，我完全不记得你运球很烂。
If you look close, I never dribbled the ball down the court. Is that right? Nope, never, never. But you're really good at guarding Dwight. You held your own. I knew how to guard. I knew how to guard. And I knew that much I knew.
如果你仔细看，我从来没有运球突破全场过。是吗？对，从来没有，从来没有。但你防守德怀特真的很厉害。你顶住了。我知道怎么防守。我知道怎么防守。这一点我还是知道的。
And then when I think I found out I had booked it and I went running to Target. And I ran and I bought a basketball. And I came home. I told my husband, you need to teach me how to dribble a basketball now. And he was like, what? And I said, you don't understand. I just booked a show and I need to learn how to play basketball. And he was like, honey, I can't teach you how to play basketball in like one weekend.
然后当我想我发现我被录用了，我一路小跑去了塔吉特。我跑着去买了一个篮球。然后我回到家。我告诉我丈夫，你现在得教我怎么运球。他当时就说，什么？我说，你不明白。我刚刚接了一部剧，我需要学会怎么打篮球。他说，亲爱的，我没办法在大概一个周末的时间里教会你打篮球。
And I said, try, please. So was that your weekend? You and your husband like trying to play basketball? It was like cramming to try and play basketball. And I sucked at it so badly. And my husband is 6'5. So it was like he really was like blocking and doing all this stuff. And he was like, try and go around me.
我说，试试看，求你了。所以那是你们的周末？你和你的丈夫试图去打篮球？那就像是为了打篮球而进行的突击恶补。我打得太烂了。而且我丈夫身高6尺5寸。所以他真的很像是在盖帽和做所有这些动作。他就会说，试着绕过我。
And I was like, I can't, you're too tall. And so I did my best. I did my best. And I practiced all weekend long. And then when I got to set, it was funny because the first day on set that I had to go through these massive wardrobe changes because Greg, Greg was like, no, that's too frilly. That's too frilly. We need to find something else. And they finally gave me the cutoff T-shirt with whatever number it was, a number 38 on it.
而我就说，我不能，你太高了。所以我尽力了。我尽了最大努力。我整个周末都在练习。然后当我到了片场，这很搞笑，因为在片场的头几天我得经历这些大规模的服装更换，因为格雷格，格雷格说，不，那个太花哨了。那个太花哨了。我们需要找点别的。他们最后给了我一件剪裁过的T恤，上面印着某个号码，38号。
Wait, what is that? Is that a picture of you from set? I made a postcard for, because I was so excited about the show. So I made a postcard to mail out because back in those days, you actually mailed out postcards as an announcement. Yeah. I did this with when I did theater in L.A. Yeah. You would put like a picture of yourself and there was like we had a quote.
等等，那是什么？那是你在片场的照片吗？我制作了一张明信片，因为我对这部剧太兴奋了。所以我制作了一张明信片用来寄出去，因为在那个年代，你真的会寄出明信片作为公告。是的。我在洛杉矶演戏剧时也这么做过。是的。你会放一张自己的照片，然后上面有引言。
We were like L.A. weekly pick of the week. Right. And then you would make a postcard and you would mail that to all the casting directors in town. When they had offices, right? I did the same thing. Backstage West. Right. And it was, so I, it was funny because they couldn't find the right outfit for me.
我们就像是洛杉矶周报评选的本周最佳。对。然后你会制作一张明信片，把它寄给镇上的所有选角导演。当他们还有办公室的时候，对吧？我也做过同样的事。后台西区。对。而且是，所以我，这很有趣，因为他们找不到适合我的服装。
And eventually they did. And so we did that. And then this postcard is amazing. That was the best shot. I don't even remember who took that. What's so great about this picture, and I'll put it in our Insta stories. You guys, it's Carly as Madge. You're dripping with sweat.
最后他们找到了。所以我们就那样做了。然后这张明信片太棒了。那是最好的一张照片。我甚至不记得是谁拍的。这张照片最棒的地方在于，我会把它发到我们的快拍里。伙计们，那是作为马奇的卡莉。你汗流浃背。
And you look like you've just played a lot of basketball. You have a really miserable expression. It's the date and time of the episode. This is fantastic. It was so much fun. I remember because I went into hair and makeup and I think, I know you were there and Katie was there. One of you was there and Katie was there.
你看上去就像刚打了好久篮球一样，表情非常痛苦。这是这一集播出的日期和时间。这太棒了，真的太有趣了。我记得因为我去了发型和化妆间，我想，我知道你在那儿，凯蒂也在那儿。你们俩其中一个在那儿，凯蒂也在那儿。
And somebody looked up at me and said, don't expect much. And I was like, what? Oh, no. Phyllis and Katie were in there. And they were like, don't expect much. It's not that kind of show. And I was like, what do you mean? And it was like, there's no, there's no makeup.
然后有人抬头看着我，说，别抱太大希望。我当时想，什么？哦，不，菲利斯和凯蒂在那儿，她们说，别抱太大希望，这不是那种类型的节目。我说，你什么意思？结果是，根本没有什么化妆。
There's, there's like nada. And I was like, I'm okay, fine. I don't, this is me. I don't wear much. I mean, Carly, you and I have the same hairstyle in this episode. I know, I know. They put it in a braid. A French braid and called it a day.
基本上可以说是压根没有。然后我说，好吧，没关系，我没问题，这就是我，我本来就不怎么化妆。卡莉，你和我在这集里梳的是同款发型。我知道，我知道，他们把头发编成了一条辫子，一条法式编发，然后就完事了。
Yeah, that was it. And I had the bangs back then. And they just kept getting sweatier and sweatier. And there was like that nobody cared about anything. The only mistake I made was, I think in the wear. has seen. I made the mistake of climbing the rolling stairs. Oh, yeah. In the first scene. And I think I had to do that 50 times. Oh, because they liked it and it had to match. It was like taking, it was like doing a stairmaster. So was that on your first day of shooting and then you had to come back
对，就是这样。那时候我还留着刘海，而且刘海越来越汗湿。根本没人会在乎这些。我唯一的失误就是，我觉得在我看到过的片段里，我犯了一个错误，就是爬了那个滚动楼梯。哦，对，在第一场戏里。我想我大概爬了50次。哦，因为他们喜欢那个镜头，而且必须连戏。那感觉就像在用楼梯机锻炼。所以那是你拍摄的第一天，然后你还得回来
and play basketball. And let's see the trailer. You know how we all had those honeywagon the very first episode. And you decorated them for Halloween. It was so cute. Kate and I, yes. We just talked about that. We went to the 99-cent store and- It was the cutest thing.
打篮球。让我们看看那个房车。你知道我们第一集的时候都有那些流动化妆车吗？你们还为万圣节装饰了它们，太可爱了。凯特和我，是的，我们刚聊过这个。我们去了99美分商店——这简直太可爱了。
Everybody had little booze and ghosts and everything. But Leslie's trailer was here and then Brian and then me or whatever. And I remember Leslie was sitting on his stairs and Brian was sitting on his and I tried to get up into my trailer. And I was like, ow. And Leslie looked at me and he goes, Arnica, Arnica. And I was like, what?
每个人都有小幽灵、小鬼魂和各种装饰。但莱斯利的车在中间，然后是布라이언，然后是我，诸如此类的。我记得莱斯利坐在他的台阶上，布赖恩坐在他的台阶上，我试图爬进我的车里，我忍不住说，噢。莱斯利看着我，对我说，山金车，山金车。我当时想，什么？
And he goes, go get yourself some arnica gel. It's the only thing. That and a hot bath. And I was like, okay. That is so Leslie, isn't it? A hot bath. Yeah. So many times he told us to take a hot bath.
然后他说，去给自己买点山金车凝胶吧，这是唯一的办法。再加上一个热水澡。我当时想，好吧。这太莱斯利了，不是吗？洗个热水澡。是的，他不知多少次让我们去洗个热水澡。
He would. Because my legs hurt so bad after the third day, and we were filming. And all I kept doing was running up and down the court, up and down, and we were on a concrete floor. Yeah. And my legs hurt so bad. It was like the third day. And I was like, I couldn't walk anymore.
他确实会。因为第三天之后我的腿疼得要命，而且我们还在拍戏。我一直在做的事情就是在球场上跑来跑去，跑上跑下，而我们踩的是水泥地面。对，而且我的腿疼得厉害。那是第三天，我觉得自己已经没法走路了。
Well, you know, we had the opposite problem. You were sitting. I know. Metal bench with no cushion for three days. And my butt and legs kept falling asleep. Or that thing that happens where, like, I also couldn't walk because I was, like, stiff from, like, sitting in the same position for hours and hours. That's, wow. Also, we, I mean, whatever, overshare, but that bench had these long grooved lines in it.
好吧，你知道，我们遇到了相反的问题。你一直坐着。我知道。坐在没有垫子的金属长椅上坐了三天，我的屁股和腿一直发麻。或者那种情况，我也没法走路，因为我连续坐了好几个小时，姿势都没变，整个人都僵硬了。天哪。还有，我们，我是说，不管怎样，虽然有点过度分享，但那张长椅上有很深的凹槽线条。
Yes. And I. When you went, when I went home and I changed clothes, I had like waffled books. Oh, no. But this is a really great tip for any aspiring actor out there. Whatever you do in the background on the first take, you will be doing over and over and over again. One of my friends had told me, like, a long time ago, never, ever, ever pick a tough job to do. Like, because on one, I think of one commercial shoot, he made the mistake of choosing a jackhammer.
是的。当我回家换衣服时，我身上甚至有那种华夫格的印记。哦，不。但这对任何有志成为演员的人来说都是一个非常棒的提示：无论你在背景里第一条拍的时候做了什么动作，你都得一遍又一遍、反反复复地做下去。我的一个朋友很久以前就告诉我，千万、千万、千万不要选一件辛苦的工作来做。比如，有一次在拍某个广告时，他犯了个错误，选了一个手持凿岩机。
Oh, no. I was like, really sorry he ever did that. And I'll never forget that because afterwards I was like, why did I choose to go up and down the stairs? Because my business was to go up the stairs and get a box and bring it down or go up the stairs and put a box up on a shell. I was like, what was I thinking? I couldn't move after. We've all done it. Oh, my God.
哦，不。我真为他当初做了这个决定感到遗憾。我永远不会忘记这件事，因为在那之后我一直在想：我当时为什么要选择上下楼梯？因为我的工作内容就是上楼去拿个盒子然后拿下来，或者上楼把盒子放进架子里。我当时心想：我脑子里在想什么呢？之后我都动不了了。我们都经历过这种事，天哪。
We have. It was like the fourth day, I think it was, or the last day. Was it the last day of shooting when I fell? I think it was. It was, thankfully. it was the last day of shooting because you didn't have to come back. You fell and hurt your knee. I did.
我们确实都经历过。那是第四天吧，我想，或者最后一天。我摔倒的那天是最后一天拍摄吗？我想是的。谢天谢地那是最后一天，这样你就不用再回来了。你摔倒并弄伤了膝盖。是的，我确实摔了。
Really badly. Oh, and I didn't want anybody to know. I thought I was going to try and hide it. I was chasing Steve down court. He went tearing after, and I went running after him, and my legs were just like not working. They just stopped working, and I just went flying, and I landed on my left knee. On the concrete. caught right on the concrete.
而且伤得很重。哦，我不想让任何人知道。我当时还想试着把这事藏起来。我当时在球场上追着史蒂夫跑，他猛冲过去，我在后面追，结果我的腿完全不听使唤了。它们就是突然罢工了，我整个人直接飞了出去，左膝重重地着地了。直接砸在水泥地上，结结实实地摔在水泥地上。
And I got up and I kept running and I kept playing and then they said cut and I immediately went back to the back where I think there was a cooler filled with ice and drinks or something like that. And I just very quickly grabbed a Ziploc baggie and filled it with ice and didn't say anything. I just kind of sat there and sat down for a minute and it was really hurting. And so I just kind of quietly came out and I sat down on the bench next to you and I had the ice back on my knee and I moved it. for a second and you looked down at my knee and you went, oh my God! And I was like, shh, yeah. I was going to say, my memory is that that thing swelled up fast. It was huge.
我爬起来继续跑，继续打球，然后他们喊了卡，我立刻退到了后台，那里好像放着一个装满冰块和饮料的冷却箱之类的东西。我非常迅速地抓了一个自封袋，往里面装满了冰块，什么也没说。我只是坐在那里，坐了一会儿，真的很痛。于是我悄悄地走出来，坐在你旁边的长椅上，把冰袋敷在膝盖上，稍微动了一下。你低头看了一眼我的膝盖，然后说：哦，天哪！我说：嘘，别出声。我正想说，我的记忆是那个伤处肿得极快，简直太大了。
Yeah. And I kind of remember being like, you got to, we got to get the medic. We got to tell somebody. Like, don't. It didn't match. It didn't, my memory was it didn't match your other knee at all. Not close. Oh, my gosh.
对。我记得当时我的反应是：你得找医务人员，我们得告诉别人。别这样。那根本不对劲。我的记忆是，它跟你的另一个膝盖完全不一样了。一点都不像。哦，天哪。
And then, Jen, I think you got the medic, didn't you? Did I? Yeah, you did. Yeah, you did. That was my memory. Well, you know, you guys, I have that part of me. Yeah. I'm like, I smell gas in the work box. I know.
然后，珍，我想是你去找的医务人员吧？是我吗？对，就是你。没错，是你。我记忆中是这样的。好吧，你知道的，你们大家，我身上就有那种爱管闲事的特质。我知道。
This entry needs attending to. She was super sweet, and she took one look, and she said, no, we're going to do an accident report. And I was sitting back in the back, and I was like, I am so mortified. I didn't want to deal it with this. It's fine. I'll be fine. And she said, no, we're going to have you have that checked out. And they filled out the forms and did the whole thing.
这个情况需要处理一下。她人超级好，看了一眼就说，不行，我们要写一份事故报告。我当时坐在后台，心想：我太尴尬了。我根本不想处理这事，没关系，我会没事的。但她说，不行，我们得带你去检查一下。于是他们填了表格，完成了全套流程。
And I was mortified because I was like, oh, my God, we're not done filming. And I'm, this is terrible and blah. And I never hurt myself on a set before. And this was my first three-day job ever, three days of filming. That was like the first, I had done two other jobs. It's a big deal. It was huge. I remember you being worried like, will they ever bring me back?
我当时尴尬得要命，心想：哦，天哪，我们还没拍完呢。这太糟糕了，诸如此类的。我以前从没在片场受过伤。而且这是我人生中头一个为期三天的群演工作，拍三天的戏。这就好比第一份工作，我之前只做过另外两份工作。这可是件大事。太重要了。我记得你当时还很担心：他们以后还会让我回来吗？
Right. Because I got hurt. And that's such a thing when you're, and. actor starting out, like an accident happens, but you're afraid you'll get branded as difficult or, like, whatever. Yeah. But that wasn't, that's, I mean, thankfully, I feel like, especially on the office, that wasn't the tone of our set.
没错。因为我受伤了。作为一个刚出道的演员，这种事很难办，出了意外，但你又担心被贴上“难搞”或者别的什么标签。是的。但那不是，那不是——我是说，谢天谢地，我觉得尤其是《办公室》剧组，我们的片场并没有那种风气。
Yeah. And you needed medical attention. And we did bring you back. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was all fine. It was, I was so grateful.
对。而且你需要医疗护理。我们也把你请回来了。对。对。对。一切都很好。真的，我太感激了。
Well, you know, I want you to know that in the superfan version on Peacock, all of your stuff with Dwight. Imagine Dwight, like going down the court against each other is all in there. In your face. And clearly that happened before you hurt your knee. Right. And you know what? I'm so glad now people will see how hard you were busting your ass on that
你知道吗，我想让你知道，在Peacock的超长粉丝版里，你和Dwight的所有对手戏——想象一下Dwight在球场上跟你针锋相对——全都在里面。针锋相对。很显然，那是在你膝盖受伤之前发生的。对吧？你知道吗？我现在特别高兴，因为大家终于能看到你在球场上有多拼了。
court. I was trying. I was, I was, uh, the who was the guy who choreographed the basketball game? There was somebody there. Oh, we had a stunt coordinator. Yeah. That choreographed the game. But then there was parts of it that, you know, you guys were just running back and forth and kind of.
我尽力了。我当时，我当时……是谁负责编排篮球赛的动作来着？当时现场有个人。哦，我们有一个特技指导。是的。他编排了整场比赛。但其中有些部分，你知道的，你们也就是跑来跑去，然后有点……
of just freestyling, but if you watch the superfan version, Madge and Dwight really square off a lot, what was that like? Because we know Rain. Rain goes all out. Yeah. There was a stunt coordinator who actually showed me how it was going to work, and it was like a choreographed thing. Mm-hmm. And then when he grabs it from me, we're supposed to fight, and there were a couple times where I think we even ended up on the ground. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. You did. Yeah. And then I was like, I'm not letting go of the ball. I'm not letting go to the ball. And he got into it and I got into it.
就有点像自由发挥。但如果你看粉丝版，梅奇（Madge）和德怀特（Dwight）真的有很多正面交锋，那是什么感觉？因为我们知道雷恩（Rainn）拍戏总是全力以赴。对。有一个特技指导实际上向我演示了动作该怎么做，这就像是一个编排好的套招。嗯哼。然后当他从我手里抢球时，我们应该要打起来，有几次我觉得我们甚至都摔到地上了。对。对。对。你们确实摔了。对。然后当时我就想，我绝不放手。我绝不放手。他来真的，我也来真的。
We started fighting. It was so much fun because he was like, I just got mad at him. I was like, back off, man. Just back off. And he goes, no, I'm not going to back off. And I'm going, get out of my face. I was like, in your face. It was really good and feels very honest.
我们真的打起来了。太好玩了，因为我就像是——我对他来火了。我当时说，走开，老兄。离我远点。他说，不，我才不走开。然后我说，离我远点！我就差贴到他脸上了。真的很棒，感觉非常真实。
But that whole storyline between Dwight and Madge reminded me of like that, you know, eight-year-old boy on like the school yard that you're playing kickball with who goes so super hard. Yeah. And you're like, buddy, relax, except it's a grown man. And if I hadn't, if I hadn't hurt myself, we almost had this little secret thing that we were going to do behind the boxes when he takes a sip of water and he spills it all over his face. Right before that, we were going to have this little secret thing behind the boxes
但德怀特和梅奇之间的整条故事线让我想起那种在学校操场上玩踢球游戏的八岁小男孩，他玩得超级投入。对。然后你会想：老兄，放松点。只不过这是个成年男人。如果我没有，如果我没有受伤的话，我们本来还有一个秘密的小桥段——就在他拿水喝、把水洒了一脸之前，我们本来打算在箱子后面拍这么一小段秘密互动——
and that never came to fruition. What secret thing? Like Dwight match hookup? Like a little row? Oh, like this was all foreplay on the court. Oh my gosh. He met his physical match and he was turned on. We were going to, we were going to come up with something and then it never happened unfortunately because, but as it turned out, obviously it never needed to happen. But, Well, I think it would have worked, and you know what have been great is if Angela found out and then really, like, then Angela hated Matt. Oh, my God. Well, speaking of scenes in the warehouse where things were added, I want to jump to the Boys and Girls episode because Dave Rogers wants you to know that he put an extra talking head of yours into boys and girls. This is when the documentary crew is filming down in the warehouse and they find Madge pushing a cart of supplies.
结果却没有实现。什么秘密桥段？就像是德怀特和梅奇有一腿？就像是一段办公室恋情？哦，原来这在球场上全都是调情！天哪。他遇到了势均力敌的对手，他被激起欲望了。我们本来打算弄出点动静，然后很遗憾地没有发生，不过事实证明，显然也没必要发生。但是，嗯，我觉得这行得通，你知道如果安吉拉（Angela）发现了，那才叫棒呢，然后安吉拉就会超级讨厌梅奇。哦，天哪！说到仓库里那些加戏的场景，我想跳到《男孩与女孩》那一集，因为戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）想让你知道，他在《男孩与女孩》里给你加了一个单独的访谈镜头。这是纪录片摄制组在仓库拍摄时，发现梅奇推着一车物资。
It's very funny. We're going to play it. Don't take me. I'm wanted in three states. Don't. Does I say don't videotape? Don't tape me. Yeah.
非常搞笑。我们要放出来了。别拍我。我在三个州都被通缉了。别拍。我刚才是不是说别拍视频？别拍我。对。
I'm wanted in three states. What is she wanted for? Oh, my God. That's hysterical. Do you even remember doing that? I feel like that must have been an improv moment. Totally. Right?
我在三个州都被通缉了。她因为什么被通缉？哦，天哪。这太爆笑了。你还记得当时拍过这个吗？我觉得那绝对是即兴发挥。完全是的。对吧？
Or something they fed you on the day. They were capturing little moments in the warehouse because right before that is Lonnie and they're filming him. He's got that giant plastic like saran wrap and he's wrapping it around the boxes. And he's like, sometimes I pretend to be a car. And then it cuts to you and you're pushing the cart and you're surly from the get-go. You have to check out some of these super fans because there's more Madge. Mm-hmm. We also want to ask you about safety training.
或者是他们在现场临时塞给你的。他们当时在捕捉仓库里的小瞬间，因为就在那之前是兰尼（Lonnie），他们在拍他。他拿着一卷巨大的塑料保鲜膜，正围着箱子缠。然后他说，有时候我假装自己是一辆汽车。接着镜头切到你，你推着推车，一开场就气势汹汹。你们一定要去看看这些粉丝版，因为里面还有更多的梅奇。嗯哼。我们还想问你关于安全培训的事。
Oh, my God. So this is the episode where Madge gets her nickname from Michael. Pudge. Yes. You are so funny in that scene. Do you know, I found the shooting script for that? That, when I saved on my computer. First of all, Harold Ramos, what?
哦，天哪。这就是梅奇从迈克尔那里得到外号的那一集。胖奇（Pudge）。是的。你在那一场戏里太搞笑了。你知道吗？我居然找到了那一集的拍摄剧本！那是存在我电脑里的。首先，哈罗德·拉姆斯（Harold Ramis），什么？
I know. What? I know. When I saw that, I almost jumped out of my skin because Avery Shriver was my mentor from Second City, and Avery and Harold and Minacolb and Severn Darden, all the original O'Gs from Second City were all, I think Harold told me this, one of the fabulous lunches that we always had together. Yes, at the big, long tables.
我知道。什么？我知道。我看到的时候，差点吓得魂飞魄散，因为艾弗里·施赖弗（Avery Shriver）是我在“第二城”（Second City）的导师，而艾弗里、哈罗德、米娜·科尔布（Minacolb）和塞弗恩·达登（Severn Darden），所有“第二城”的元老级人物全都在——我想哈罗德是这么告诉我的——在我们总是聚在一起的那些美妙午餐之一上。对，就在那张又长又大的桌子旁。
Yes, that's one of the things I love about this cast, is that every time from the first, week when we shot basketball, we all sat down family style. I mean, the first week I had dinner with you guys. I sat down with John Krasinski and his parents. Do you remember that? He brought his parents to that episode. Yeah. And I was like, oh, my God. And Harold sat there telling Second City stories. Yeah. And it was Harold and DJ and me and Phyllis and you. I mean, it was like, I'm having lunch with Harold Ramos. What is happening? And he told Second City. stories that were just irreplaceable. So that was a gift to have that moment. And in the safety training episode, there were no, God bless B.J. Novak, he wrote me into the episodes I was in.
是的，这也是我最喜欢这个剧组的地方之一，那就是从我们拍摄篮球赛的第一周开始，我们大家就像一家人一样坐在一起吃饭。我是说，第一周我和你们一起吃过晚餐。我和约翰·克拉辛斯基（John Krasinski）以及他的父母坐在一起。你还记得吗？他带他父母来拍那一集了。对。然后我就想，哦，天哪。哈罗德就坐在那儿讲“第二城”的故事。对。当时在场的有哈罗德、DJ、我、菲利斯（Phyllis）还有你。我是说，我就像是在和哈罗德·拉姆斯一起吃午饭。这到底是怎么回事？他讲的“第二城”故事简直是无价之宝。所以能拥有那个时刻真是一份大礼。在安全培训那一集里，没有——上帝保佑B.J.诺瓦克（B.J. Novak），他把我写进了我参演的剧集里。
It was because he wrote me in. I didn't have any lines. And we were just all standing there. And then he said, her, her is qualified to ride the forklift. And Lonnie kind of nudged me. And I went, Madge. It's Madge. And Steve looked at me and he goes, I thought your name was Pudge. And I'm like, no, it's always been Madge. And I looked over it.
就是因为他把我写进去了。我本来一句台词都没有。然后我们大家就都站在那儿。接着他说：她，她有资格开叉车。然后兰尼用胳膊肘碰了碰我，我就说：是梅奇。我是梅奇。史蒂夫（Steve）看着我，然后他说：我还以为你叫胖奇呢。我说：不，我一直叫梅奇。然后我转过头去——
And you guys were all busting up. And I was like, it was so funny. So funny. Well, you know, in Boys and Girls, one of my favorite moments is the character reveal that you're there. Because it's just the men in a circle. Guy's scribe session. Yeah. Yeah.
然后你们全都笑喷了。我就觉得，这也太搞笑了。太搞笑了。嗯，你知道，在《男孩与女孩》中，我最喜欢的时刻之一就是你的角色登场时的揭晓。因为当时只有男人们围成一圈。男人们的密谋会议。对。对。
And then you lean forward. And there you are. And it busts me up every time I watch it. Denny snuck that one. I love her. She was so much fun. We were all sitting on boxes, and she was like, hide behind David and John. And I was like, what?
然后你身体前倾。你就出现在那里了。每次我看的时候都把我笑死。丹妮（Danny）巧妙地安排了这一出。我太喜欢她了。我们都坐在箱子上，她就说：藏在大卫（David）和约翰身后。然后我就想：什么？
Okay. And then I think somehow or another, David out of the corner of his eye looks back at me. Or he looks out of the corner of his eye to, like, indicate to Michael, there's somebody else here. Right. You're getting it wrong. And then I just kind of leave it. forward and I was like, hey, you want me to go? And then Steve got this look on his face, like, no, why would I, why would I want you to go? And I was like, because I don't belong here, you
好吧。然后我想不知怎么的，大卫用眼角余光回头看了看我。或者他用眼角余光瞥了一眼，以此来暗示迈克尔，这里还有别人。对。你记错了。然后我就顺势前倾，然后我说：嘿，你想让我去吗？接着史蒂夫脸上露出了那种表情，好像在说：不，我为什么——我为什么会想让你去？然后我说：因为我不属于这里，你个
moron. Why am I not upstairs with the women? What part of this? I so wish Madge had come upstairs. Wouldn't that have been so fun? I would have been really, really fun to have you come upstairs. And be part of the insane conversation we were having. You guys were having. Yeah. I know. That would have been wonderful. But it was funny. It was funny. And Danny choreographed that really well. She was just like. And when I walk by him, the expression on his face was just priceless. So wonderful. It was just priceless. That was fun. That was very, very fun. Can we also discuss some deleted scenes from Secret Santa? Yes. Do you remember these? Do you know what I'm going to say?
笨蛋。我为什么不跟楼上的女人们在一起？这到底是怎么回事？我多希望梅奇能去楼上啊。那难道不是超级好玩吗？如果你能去楼上，绝对会非常、非常有趣。并且加入我们当时正在進行的疯狂对话。你们当时正在进行。对。我知道。那会太棒了。但真的很搞笑。太搞笑了。而且丹妮那个镜头调度得真好。她当时就……当我从他身边走过时，他脸上的表情简直无价。太精彩了。简直无价。太好玩了。真的、真的太好玩了。我们能顺便讨论一下《秘密圣诞老人》（Secret Santa）里的一些删减片段吗？可以。你们还记得这些吗？你们知道我要说什么吗？
My Garfield Pusts. Yes. Yes. Well, it's been added back to the Peacock Superfan episode. Let me set it up and then we're going to listen to it. Okay. So this is the party that Jim and Dwight are planning, and Jim is nervous because the warehouse folks have now been invited to this party, and they're worried that they're not going to have enough food. So everybody's standing in line from the warehouse to get food, and he says, it's just finger foods.
我的加菲猫，是的。是的。好吧，它被重新加到了孔雀超级粉丝单集里。让我先铺垫一下，然后我们再来听听看。好的。所以这是吉姆和德怀特正在策划的派对，吉姆感到很紧张，因为仓库的员工现在也被邀请参加这个派对，他们担心食物会不够。所以每个人都在从仓库到拿食物的队伍里排队，他说，这只是指尖小吃。
kind of like, please don't take a lot, and one lasagna, and then here's what happens. So guys, it's just more like finger food. Uh-oh, a lasagna. Look out, Garfield. Uh-oh. What does that mean?
有点像，请大家不要拿太多，还有一份千层面，然后接下来发生的事是这样的。所以伙计们，这更像是手指小吃。哦哦，一份千层面。小心点，加菲猫。哦哦。那是什么意思？
Oh, they call me Garfield. I've never seen a lasagna not eating the whole pan. Oh, I wish you wouldn't. Oh, well, I can't help myself. Can you imagine what it's like for me that it has that power over me? I got to have some. Sorry, guys. Everybody gets them?
哦，他们叫我加菲猫。我从来没见过有人吃千层面不把一整盘吃光的。哦，我希望你别这样。哦，好吧，我控制不住自己。你能想象这对我有多大诱惑吗，它对我有这么大的吸引力？我得吃点。对不起，伙计们。每个人都有吗？
I got mine. Okay. Okay, so that's the scene, but then what happens? We're outside of the conference room. Yeah. And inside the conference room, you are eating all of the rest of the lasagna, and all the warehouse guys are screaming. Garfield, Garfield, Garfield. How much lasagna did you eat?
我拿到了。好的。好的，这就是那个场景，但接下来发生了什么？我们在会议室外面。是的。而在会议室里面，你在吃剩下所有的千层面，所有的仓库员工都在大喊。加菲猫，加菲猫，加菲猫。你吃了多少千层面？
That's our question. A half a pan. Oh. No, no, I had a spit bucket. Okay. spit bucket. They had three changes, shirt changes, which I didn't need because I was very careful. But there was a spit bucket right there. And I think you were the one that suggested that I needed one. Thank you. You know why? Do you know how we all say, be careful what you do in the background.
这就是我们的问题。半盘。哦。不，不，我准备了一个吐痰桶。好吧。吐痰桶。他们换了三次衬衫，换了三次，其实我不需要，因为我很小心。但那里确实放着一个吐痰桶。我想就是你建议我需要准备一个的。谢谢你。你知道为什么吗？你知道为什么我们总说，在背景里做事要小心吗？
Mine was the very first time we ate ice cream cake. It was the scene, it was the Alliance and it was Meredith's birthday. And I took a big old bite of that ice cream cake at 7 in the morning. I was so excited. And then we ate it for hours. I thought that's it. I can't, I still to this day, like, I'm like, I don't want any ice cream cake. No. Yeah. Spit bucket. And it was good.
我那次是我这辈子第一次吃冰淇淋蛋糕。那是那个场景，是同盟那一集，那是梅丽迪斯的生日。我在早上7点钟狠狠地咬了一大口那个冰淇淋蛋糕。我当时太兴奋了。然后我们连着吃了好几个小时。我想就是这样。我不能，直到今天，我都觉得，我再也不想吃冰淇淋蛋糕了。不。对。吐痰桶。而且它很好吃。
I mean, it was delicious because whoever it crafty made it, it was wonderful. But after about the fourth time. The fourth half of lasagna you ate. Fourth half of lasagna, yeah. Well, because they left, I think whoever did it left me, like, in the trade, they left me, like, this quarter. So I just had to really. put the whole thing up and just scoop it in like that. Yeah, because you're like shoving it in your mouth. Yeah. And the whole quarter of the pan is up like this. But the funny part was when I
我是说，它很好吃，因为不管是哪个道具组做的，它真的很棒。但在大约第四次之后。你吃的第四个半千层面。第四个半盘千层面，是的。好吧，因为他们离开时，我想不管是谁留给我的，在转场时，他们留给我了，就像四分之一盘。所以我不得不。把整块都拿起来，然后就像那样铲进去。是的，因为你就像是把它往嘴里塞。是的。整整四分之一盘的千层面就这么举着。但有趣的是，当我
walked in, I had worked so hard on my lines because I wanted to get them right because it's my first scene with John. And he completely improvised. And I was like, oh, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I was going to improvise something. And I was like, no, that's fine. I just was ready for something. else. And he said, no, I'll do the other thing. I was like, okay, but I'm fine now that I know you were going to go off in a different direction. He was like, no, no, no, I'll stick to what we got. I was like, sorry. So I got really nervous after that. And then Craig started chanting Garfield, Garfield, and I was like, please don't do that. I'm going to laugh. I'm going to laugh and choke to death. Please don't do that. But then this spit bucket happened. And then we shot it and I didn't
走进来的时候，我对自己的台词下了很大功夫，因为我想把它说对，毕竟这是我和约翰的对手戏。结果他完全即兴发挥了。当时我就想，哦，对不起。对不起。我本打算即兴发挥一下什么的。然后我说，没关系。我只是对别的东西有所准备。他说，不，我会用另一个。我说，好吧，但既然我知道你要往另一个方向发挥了，我现在没问题了。他却说，不，不，不，我还是照我们原本的来吧。我说，对不起。所以我之后变得非常紧张。然后克雷格开始喊加菲猫，加菲猫，我就想，求求你别这样。我要笑了。我会笑到窒息的。求求你别这样做。但接着这个吐痰桶就派上用场了。然后我们拍完了，我没有
get any shirts dirty. And I was like, okay, I did that right, did that right. Everything's cool. and we finished shooting, and then they said, okay, let's take a break. Everybody go and, you know, Crafty set up lunch, and I walk outside, and I open the lid, and they're serving lasagna, and I go, oh, look, lasagna. It was probably all the lasagna's we didn't use in the scene. Yeah. They're like, we know what we're going to do with the extra lasagna. Somebody said, Carly gets quoted the day, so I got quoted the day on the sheet.
弄脏任何一件衬衫。当时我想，好的，我做对了，这下做对了。一切都好。我们拍完了，然后他们说，好啦，大家休息一下。所有人去，你知道的，道具组准备了午餐，我走到外面，打开盖子，他们正在端上千层面，我说，哦，看呐，千层面。这大概就是我们在场景里没吃完的所有千层面吧。是的。他们就像是在说，我们知道怎么处理多余的千层面了。有人说，卡莉成了今日金句，所以我被写进了表格的今日金句里。
On the call sheet? Oh, yeah. I was like, oh, no, I didn't mean to be ungrateful, but LaSania for lunch, yay. No, everybody got it. That was brilliant. It was great. I'm like, oh, no. Well, I wanted to ask you about the day that we learned, the scorn.
在通告单上？哦，是的。当时我想，哦，不，我不是故意要显得不知感恩的，但是午餐吃千层面，耶。不，每个人都懂。太棒了。真的太棒了。我想，哦，不。好吧，我想问你关于我们学那个斯康舞的那天的事。
Do you remember that? I do. We all had to practice in that side room. Yes. That was hysterical. And I was so worried I wasn't going to get it right. I can't dance, Carly. I just can't.
你还记得吗？我记得。我们所有人都在那个侧室里练习。是的。那太滑稽了。我当时超级担心自己学不会。我不会跳舞，卡莉。我真的不会。
It's like you have to really break it down for me. I think you can see me counting. But that was so fun. That was hysterical. They made me change my hair because I had a braid and you had a braid. Even though in basketball it was okay that we both had the same hair, I guess, for the scorn. They wanted us to have different hair. Yeah, I had to have different hair.
就像你得一点一点给我拆解动作一样。你大概能看到我在数拍子。但那真的太好玩了。太滑稽了。他们让我换了发型，因为我扎了辫子，你也有辫子。虽然在篮球那一集里我们留一样的发型没问题，但我想为了斯康舞。他们希望我们的发型不一样。是的，我必须换发型。
I sat at the bar with Jean and Lee and Lee. Yeah. Because they were in it. I remember they positioned us a little bit by height. Yeah. So I was in the front because I'm shorty, shorty. They went shorter and then taller, so on and so forth. You know, threat level midnight was another B.J. Novak script.
我和简还有李坐在一起。是的。因为他们也参演了。我记得他们是按身高给我们排位的。是的。所以我站在前面，因为我是个小不点。他们按从矮到高，以此类推。你知道的，惊天危机另一个B.J.诺瓦克的剧本。
So he really did bring you back a lot. He wrote me in literally once a season. Oh, that's great. So if it wasn't for him and Mindy, I would not have been in like almost every season. Wow. Yeah. And I always, whenever I came back, I always said, thank you for writing me in. He said, my pleasure.
所以他确实经常把你找回来。他几乎每季都会把我写进去。哦，那太棒了。所以如果不是因为他和敏迪，我可能就没法几乎每季都出场了。哇。是的。而且我每次回来，我都会说，谢谢你把我写进剧本里。他说，这是我的荣幸。
And it was literally like once a season. That's great. Yeah. I mean, we've definitely noticed over the years of rewatching the show themes that writers were drawn to some characters and would bring them back. So I love that. I'm incredibly grateful. All right. Well, listen, why don't we take a break?
而且真的就差不多每季一次。太棒了。是的。我的意思是，这些年重温这部剧时我们确实发现，编剧们会对某些角色情有独钟，并会让他们回归。所以我很喜欢这样。我真的非常感激。好吧，听着，我们为什么不休息一下呢？
And then when we come back, we're going to ask you our call sheet questions. And we're going to ask you our office question of the week. All right, we are back, and it is time for the call sheet questions. I'm going to kick us off with number one. Carly, what was your first entertainment job? The first official entertainment job was my friend John Putch hired me for my first Hallmark movie, and it was with Louise Fletcher. Whoa.
等我们回来后，我们要问你通告单的问题。我们还要问你每周办公室之问。好的，我们回来了，是时候回答通告单的问题了。我先来出第一个。卡莉，你的第一份娱乐行业工作是什么？第一份官方的娱乐行业工作是我的朋友约翰·帕奇雇我去拍我的第一部霍马克电影，那是和路易丝·弗莱彻合作的。哇。
Oh, oh, oh. I mean, and Doris Roberts, and Dana Delaney. Wow. And it was a hallmark picture called A Time to Remember. It was also with my friend Michael Dean Jacobs, literally, like a direct hire, like John wanted to hire me. And I played cousin Connie, which was sister, cousin Connie. Doris Roberts was Dana Delaney's mom, who had Alzheimer's. and Louise Fletcher played Aunt Billy.
哦，哦，哦。我的意思是，还有多丽丝·罗伯茨，以及达娜·德拉尼。哇。那是一部名叫《值得铭记的时光》的霍马克电影。它也是和我朋友迈克尔·迪恩·雅各布斯合作的，可以说是直接被录用的，就像约翰想雇佣我一样。我饰演康妮表妹，也就是修女康妮表妹。多丽丝·罗伯茨饰演达娜·德拉尼的母亲，她患有老年痴呆症，而路易丝·弗莱彻饰演比利阿姨。
And it was a Thanksgiving movie called The Time to Remember, and it plays literally on Hallmark every Thanksgiving. Oh, no way. Yeah, and that was my first big job. And I was, like, on set for, like, three days, and I just looked at him, and I said, you sat me next to Louise Fletcher at a Thanksgiving table, and he says, just enjoy the ride.
那是一部关于感恩节的电影，名叫《值得铭记的时光》，而且每到感恩节它都会在霍马克频道重播。哦，不会吧。是的，那是我的第一份大工作。而且我在片场待了大概三天，我看着他，我说，你把我和路易丝·弗莱彻安排在感恩节餐桌上相邻的座位上，他说，尽情享受这段旅程吧。
And I was like, I'm sitting next to Nurse Ratchet. Yeah. That's Nurse Ratchett. All right. Question number two. Do you speak any other languages? I speak French, sort of, because I took it in junior high. So a little.
当时我觉得，我正坐得离拉切特护士（Nurse Ratched）很近。对啊。那就是拉切特护士。好了。第二个问题。你会说其他语言吗？我会说一点法语，算是会吧，因为我初中时学过。所以会一点。
A bit de Francaise. Sounds good to me. It got me through living in Paris for a month. That's pretty good. Because I was with the touring company of Hair. When I was in New York, I auditioned for it when I was training in New York, and I got the international touring company of hair. That's amazing. So you did hair?
会一点法语（Un peu de français）。听起来挺好。这让我撑过了在巴黎的一个月。那挺不错的。因为我当时跟着音乐剧《毛发》（Hair）的巡回剧团。当我在纽约时，我在纽约培训期间去试镜了，然后我拿到了《毛发》国际巡回剧团的角色。太棒了。所以你演了《毛发》？
Yeah. Okay. Wait, what hair is famous for? We all know how that goes at the end. Did you do it? I did because I was in Paris and nobody in Paris knew me and they all used to seeing naked people on this date. So nobody knew me. Wow.
对。好吧。等等，《毛发》以什么闻名？我们都知道最后是怎么回事。你演了吗？我演了，因为我在巴黎，巴黎没有人认识我，而且他们在那时候对裸体的人见怪不怪了。所以没人认识我。哇。
I was a lot younger. That was 1984. Carly, you are an onion. There are layers. No. All right. Next question. What's a place you've been to that you absolutely loved?
我当时年轻得多。那是1984年。卡莉，你真像个洋葱。层层有惊喜。没有啦。好吧。下一个问题。你去过哪个地方是你绝对非常喜欢的？
I love Hawaii. I love any place in Hawaii. I was also very, very fortunate to take two really cool trips with my first one was to Kenya with my mom and dad. Oh, wow. They wanted to take me on safari, so I got to go. to Tanzania and the Serengeti with my mom and dad. That was in 2009. And then my dad wanted to take me on a cruise to Greece. I enjoyed that trip with him and his new wife. My mom passed away in 2018, but I got to go with him and his new wife. I'd have to say Alaska was the last place
我爱夏威夷。我爱夏威夷的任何地方。我也非常非常幸运能有两次非常酷的旅行，第一次是和我爸妈一起去肯尼亚。哦，哇。他们想带我去看野生动物，所以我去了坦桑尼亚和塞伦盖蒂，和我爸妈一起。那是在2009年。然后我爸爸想带我坐游轮去希腊。我很享受和她以及他新妻子一起的那次旅行。我妈妈在2018年去世了，但我得以和爸爸以及他新妻子一起去。我得说阿拉斯加是最后一个地方
that we got to go, that was really cool. I love Alaska. I love the air. It's so beautiful and clean. But you've traveled a lot. Mostly because my dad is a big traveler and he's been kind enough to sort of like include the family always. So that's kind of cool. It's interesting to me, though, of all of these places you've been in the world, your first instinct was to say Hawaii. There's something about Hawaii. It's just magical. That's kind of like where my soul would go. If I could just get on a plane and go, I would go to Hawaii. It's a great answer. I love where my soul would go. I like that phrase. All right. Next question. What do you like to do on the weekends?
我们去过的那个真的很酷。我爱阿拉斯加。我爱那里的空气。它是那么美丽和清新。但你旅行过很多地方。主要是因为我爸爸是个热爱旅行的人，而且他一直很友善，总是把全家人带上。所以这挺酷的。不过对我来说有趣的是，在你去过的世界上所有地方中，你的第一直觉竟然是说夏威夷。夏威夷有某种特质。它就是那么神奇。那简直就像是我的灵魂会去的地方。如果我能直接跳上飞机出发，我会去夏威夷。这是一个很棒的回答。我喜欢“我的灵魂会去的地方”这句话。我喜欢这个说法。好的。下一个问题。你周末喜欢做什么？
I like to garden. I like to garden and I like to bake. My grandfather was a baker. And he had a bakery in Queens. And he was a pastry chef. So I sort of inherited a little bit, But not as much skill, that's for sure. But I love gardening. And when the sun is out and it's just crisp, cool weather, that's sort of my favorite time to do. So I plant daffodils and sort of try and keep my backyard in order, which now with three dogs is a little more difficult. Yeah. I like gardening.
我喜欢园艺。我喜欢园艺，我还喜欢烘焙。我外祖父是个面包师。他在皇后区有一家面包店。他是一名糕点师。所以我算是继承了一点基因，不过手艺绝对没那么好。但我热爱园艺。当太阳出来，天气又清爽又凉爽的时候，那算是我最喜欢去干活的时候了。所以我种了水仙花，并且试着把后院打理得井井有条，现在养了三只狗之后，这变得有点难了。对。我喜欢园艺。
I love all that. Okay. Last question. Okay, dook. What is your favorite midnight snack? Dark chocolate anything. Dark chocolate caramel with the sea salt. Oh, yes.
我喜欢这一切。好吧。最后一个问题。好的，小可爱（dook）。你最喜欢的午夜小吃是什么？任何黑巧克力的东西。带海盐的黑巧克力焦糖。哦，对。
Forget it all day long. Yeah. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. All right. Last thing is our office question of the week. So we really enjoyed last week we got a would-you-rather question for Lisa in Calgary when we spoke with Terry Weinberg. I love Terry Weinberg.
全天候来一杯，想都别想直接吃。对。嗯-hmm。嗯-hmm。好的。最后一件事是我们本周的办公室问题。所以我们非常喜欢上周，当我们与特里·温伯格（Terry Weinberg）交谈时，我们收到了一个来自卡尔加里的丽莎的“你宁愿（Would you rather）”问题。我爱特里·温伯格。
I know. She's the best. Well, in honor of you being here, Carly, we thought we could do a wear. Warehouse-related, would-you-rather question, an office warehouse. Here it is. Would you rather, this is as you. Okay. As you.
我知道。她是最棒的。那么，为了庆祝你的到来，卡莉，我们觉得我们可以做一个与仓库相关的“你宁愿”问题，一个办公室仓库的。题目是这样的。你宁愿，这就当是问你的。好的。就当是问你。
Carly. Carly. Not match. Right. Would Carly rather play in the basketball game against Michael or attend Michael Scott's Men in the Workplace Seminar? You have to attend one of these events. Which one would you go to?
卡莉。卡莉。不是马奇（Match）。对。卡莉宁愿在篮球赛中对阵迈克尔，还是去参加迈克尔·斯科特的“职场男性研讨会”？你必须参加其中一个活动。你会去哪一个？
Your face has the pained expression. They're both horrible choices. That's the whole point of which you rather, right? As long as I don't hurt myself again, I'd rather redeem myself in the basketball game. Okay. That's fair. But I missed out on, I never got to be in the conference room. So I think your answer is that you would rather attend the women in the workplace.
你的脸露出了痛苦的表情。它们都是糟糕的选择。这就是“你宁愿”这个游戏的全部意义，对吧？只要我不再受伤，我宁愿在篮球比赛中赎回自己。好吧。这很公平。但我错过了，我从来没进过会议室。所以你的回答是你宁愿去参加职场女性研讨会吗？
Women in the workplace seminar. Up in the conference room. Angela, what do you pick? You have to go to one of these events. Oh, man. I mean, I love sports, but I think I would want to be in the men in the workplace seminar
“职场女性”研讨会。在楼上的会议室里。安吉拉，你选哪个？你必须去参加其中一个活动。哦，天哪。我是说，我热爱运动，但我想我更愿意去参加职场男性研讨会
just because it would be ridiculous with Michael running it. And I think I'd like to ask stupid questions that I know are stupid. Oh, just to frustrate him to watch him meltdown. Oh, that would be fun. Like, just something like, can we discuss belts?
仅仅因为如果由迈克尔来主持，那一定会荒谬透顶。而且我想我会喜欢问一些明知很蠢的愚蠢问题。哦，就是为了挫败他，看他情绪崩溃。哦，那会很有趣。比如，就问一些诸如，我们能讨论一下皮带吗？
Yeah. Do I have to wear a belt? Okay. I don't know. Why do I have to have my hair back in your house? Yeah, exactly. Well, Jenna, what about you? I would want to play in the basketball game.
对。我必须系皮带吗？好吧。我不知道。为什么我的头发必须扎在你的房子里？对，完全正确。那么，珍娜，你呢？我想去打篮球。
Yay. I think it would be fun. I would enjoy that more than having to sit through a Michael Scott seminar. Okay. That's me. Sam, Cassie, what would you like? We should have a women's basketball game. Yeah.
耶。我觉得那会很有趣。比起枯坐着听迈克尔·斯科特的研讨会，我会更享受那个。好吧。这就是我的选择。萨姆，卡西，你们想选什么？我们应该举办一场女子篮球赛。对。
We know Cassie's answer. Sign me up for basketball, please. Mm-hmm. Yeah. I got to go with Michael's. men's meeting. Sam, can I just say this is often how we're split that is often meeting you. And then Jen and Cassie.
我们知道卡西的答案。请把我的名字报上打篮球，谢谢。嗯-hmm。对。我得选迈克尔的男性会议。萨姆，我能说这就是我们经常意见分歧的方式吗，通常都是你，然后是珍和卡西。
Well, Carly, thank you so much for coming into the studio and sharing your things and your stories and your memories. It was my pleasure. Absolutely my pleasure. I'm so happy to see you guys and to share such fun memories. It's wonderful. It warms my heart. you for having me. It's my pleasure. Thank you so much. Thank you. And hey, everyone, be sure to check
好吧，卡莉，非常感谢你来到演播室，分享你的物品、你的故事和你的回忆。这是我的荣幸。绝对是我的荣幸。我很高兴见到你们，并分享这么有趣的回忆。这太棒了。这温暖了我的心。谢谢你们邀请我。这是我的荣幸。非常感谢。谢谢。还有，嘿，大家，一定记得查看
your feeds on Friday because we've got a special holiday bonus episode coming your way with Ms. Kate Flannery. That's right. I love Katie. We'll see you then. Yay. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你们星期五的动态，因为我们有一个特别的节日彩蛋单集要带给你们，嘉宾是凯特·弗兰纳里（Kate Flannery）女士。没错。我爱凯蒂。我们到时候见。耶。感谢收听《办公室女士》（Office Ladies。《办公室女士》是Audience的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fischer）和安吉拉·金西（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制作人是卡西·杰金斯（Cassie Jerkins）。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗（Sam Kiefer），我们的副制作人是艾因斯利·布比科（Ainsley Bubbicoe）。Audience的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Schultz）混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Ruppertry》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。